- I really feel like
this my Oscar moment,
you know what I mean?
- Daniel Day Lewis
could suck your--
- How's the acting going, Gary?
- How did you know
I was an actor?
- I get you're new to Hollywood.
- I'm a dramatic actor,
I just moved to town.
I'm ready to act.
- Yes, thank you.
(slapping)
- Ah!
- There's no way this
little guy's an actor.
- Oh yeah I am, I'm on season 69
of How I Fucked Your Mother.
- Bad.
- Rick's god, yeah, he's,
yeah he's sober-ish.
- I got your back,
dude, we're a duo.
- Who's this sexy
actor, all right.
- He's not an actor, this
is my best friend, Rick.
- I think actors are
fucking stupid. (laughing)
- Oh, yes!
- What softens Gary
from Gary-gram?
(laughing)
- You're in the game now.
- Yeah, my name's Gary,
I am new to Los Angeles.
(snappy music)
Yeah man, totally,
solve the world, Rick.